throughout this course we've looked at
the ways in which
scientific discoveries have forced us to
alter our view of reality
but it's not just scientific advances
that have this power
technological developments have also
changed our view
of what's real
in the contemporary mind we often
conflate science and technology
we think of them as the same thing or as
flip sides of the same coin
now perhaps it's our profit-focused
presumptions or
the strength of their self-interest but
anytime you hear someone try to justify
scientific research
the grails upon which it's done are
invariably invoke
the technology that comes out as a
result of the research
why spend money on space exploration
well look at all the household products
we now have because of nasa's work
knowledge itself we often think is not
valuable even if it does cause us to
revise our picture of reality
it's only that which we can make life
longer more convenient or more
entertaining
that we consider valuable we often think
of human progress
largely if not solely in terms of the
material development of our technology
we are more advanced we are better off
then
or more strongly we are better than
those who came before us because we have
computers smartphones antibiotics space
flights you name it
some believe that if those in the past
were as advanced as we are
as good as we are they would have had
those things too
others think it's not our knowledge that
defines us
that makes us who we are it's the
gadgets we've created with it
it's the tools we use it's the lifestyle
we've been able to adopt
because of the objects we've created
with the knowledge we've acquired
and still others hold that it's the
knowledge we gain through scientific
research
it's interesting for yeah those nerdy
folks who are into that kind of stuff
but in the end it's not important in
itself
knowledge without application is
pointless they argue
ideas are only valuable insofar as the
effect life has left
insofar as they will allow us to meet
our needs
in more efficient ways insofar as they
serve
our goals
standard understanding of technology
holds that we have pre-existing goals
and technology is the set of tools we
create to help us reach them
when we can do what we needed done or
wanted done more efficiently
we have more time to create to discover
to flourish as humans
technology is a part of human progress
because it allows us the time and space
to be more human it frees us from the
tedious necessities of life
in order to grant us the ability to
pursue
our real interests
but it has long been argued that this
progressive picture of technology is
flawed
technology the line goes does not free
us from
anything in fact the reverse is true
that we become
slaves to our technology technology is
not our tool
it's our master it governs what we do
what we think what our goals are when
you have a hammer
everything starts to look like a nail if
you have a hammer
you want nails you need nails you never
have enough nails
consider possibly the most important
technology in the history of humanity
the alphabet now we have written
language so
deeply embedded in our sense of the
world that we often fail to realize that
the alphabet that writing itself
is a technology but it is
think about thinking we think that we
think in language
we think that we're like cartoon
characters who when thinking have little
bubbles over our heads with sentences in
them
no sentences no thought no language no
thought
surely our ancestors who had no language
could still
think the technology of language has so
permeated us that we don't see it as a
technology
but mistakenly think it's a natural part
of
us and thus we see ourselves through
this technology
the changed human becoming the natural
human
but once we realize that language is a
technology
an engineered addition to human life not
a natural part of it
we realize that the way we treat our own
inner lives
is determined in large part because of
our technology
our tools make things possible that
otherwise could not be
and we embed ourselves in the world of
these possibilities
in a way that makes our own being a
byproduct of our technology
add more technology and you get human
life completely reshaped
things we never needed suddenly become
necessities
and then we need the accessories for our
necessities and the accessories become
necessities
our entire way of life can be completely
altered
in one sense this is worrisome right
walk down the street and eyes are
down glued to smartphones real human
contact is minimized
often people don't talk because they're
so busy texting
but this interpersonal isolation
could if considered properly be a good
thing
the german philosopher martin heidegger
in his article
the question concerning technology
argues that
technologies create worlds and reveal
truths
technology at its best has the power of
poetry
to reveal ourselves and the world to us
technology is a creative revisioning
of how the world could be and then
changing the world accordingly
elements that were hidden become
accentuated aspects we thought were
necessary are seen as arbitrary
choices we never realized we had become
possibilities
think about the alphabet again here's a
technology that has
unbelievable power to create worlds and
to travel in time think of every book
you've ever read
and when and where it was written think
about the quotations that make you
reflect
think about puns right puns are only
possible
once we have written language we learn
from studying etymologies
right how our language has changed as a
reflection of how human culture has
changed
this door to ourselves requires
this technology
but heidegger argues if we take the
wrong approach to technology
it will not only fail to create worlds
it will
endanger them when we become captured by
our technology
it dictates our goals and frames the
world
limits our view of it and keeps truth
from being revealed by shielding our
eyes from the rest of the world left
unseen
the earth becomes just a coal mine to be
exploited
not a glorious mystery to be explored
and delighted in
heidegger's writing in 1949 when
technology has done in
two world wars what we never thought
possible
world war one introduced chemical
weapons that caused
horrible painful deaths mechanized
weapons
that could kill large numbers of victims
at once effortlessly
and from a distance without seeing their
faces
the use of airplanes and zeppelins
allowed death to come from the sky
and submarines were deployed so death
could come from beneath the water
world war ii brought atomic weapons and
the possibility
of complete global annihilation
how is it that we were able to do this
to ourselves because
heidegger argues we've allowed our
technology to redefine the very notion
of humanity
in accord with its own limitations
being with a capital b is defined
by our technology and since technology
shields off part of the world
it shields us from parts of ourselves it
limits our horizon and thereby
limits our growth we use technology to
achieve
our meagre utilitarian ends instead of
engaging
in fully creative acts that would create
the world and disclose truth
in another work his massive book being
in time
heidegger contends that the starting
point for this disclosure of truth
is the glimpsing of death
every one of us he contends has the
shocking realization
that we are finite beings that we will
die
that our time is limited it's only
by seeing that our lifetimes will have
an end point
that we can project ourselves into that
bounded future
the moments of our life are made
meaningful by the fact that they will
end
humans are beings who plan we envision
ourselves being more than we are and
then we make it so
who we are hiding or thinks is
determined by who we want to be
but because we only have a limited
amount of time
we have to make choices we can't be
everything
we don't have enough time we have to
design ourselves
as a project we select in the time we
may or may not have
because we are mortal the life
do have acquires meaning
but if you look at some of our most
prized technologies especially those
we're putting the most resources towards
it seems that they're created with the
goal of immortality
that through them we're trying to
destroy every path
where we could meet our mortal end
medical science comes up with drugs
and procedures to cure diseases and heal
injuries we pasteurize and radiate
food to kill microbes we put airbags in
cars and guard rails on the sides of
roads
your seat cushion acts as a flotation
device we put fire retardant in
children's pajamas
and asbestos in the walls until we
discovered
they caused cancer
we have the grim reaper on the run at
every turn
we think death is bad death is evil and
we put up large sums of money to try to
make ourselves immortal
benjamin franklin said that in this
world nothing can be certain except
death and taxes
we use lots and lots of technology to
try to avoid the first
and aggressive accounting methods in
offshore's tax havens to take care of
the second
cheating on your taxes i won't discuss
but cheating death
is it also cheating us of a meaningful
life
does our death-defying technology help
us become more human
better living through chemistry or does
it make us
less human
it depends of course on what we mean by
the word
human we do use death to distinguish
human from non-human right the instant
before someone passes away
we may say he is in the bed but the
moment after he passes we say
his body is in the bed we use the terms
body or corpse to indicate that the
deceased is no longer considered a
person
but what property of the body is it
that we use to determine dead from alive
now traditionally we use minimal
functioning of bodily systems
we need to have blood flowing through
the body to deliver oxygen to the cells
the blood only flows if the heart is
beating
a person is alive if he or she has a
heartbeat
technology has made this definition
problematic in a number of ways
we have automated external
defibrillators which are capable of
shocking a non-beating heart
back into service we say of someone who
has received this treatment or
successful cpr
cardiopulmonary resuscitation that she
was
dead but brought back to life
but while we think of the person as
having been dead
we usually don't think of them as having
stopped
being a person
death as a removal of personhood
seems to require permanent death and not
merely
temporary death the person was as
miracle mack said in the princess bride
only mostly dead intervention
that allows the body to regain its
ability to maintain itself
implies that continuing life was
possible and it seems that where there
is this possibility
personhood is maintained but the idea of
using the body's potential to maintain
or regain its functionality as a
condition of personhood
becomes more complicated when we
consider life support technology
we can artificially keep the blood
flowing and keep the lungs inflating
we can hook people up to machines that
function like working kidneys
are those who are on the machines still
human
in the full sense of the word we have no
question like this when it comes to
prosthetic aids for other bodily
functions
these seem to be more than just window
dressing they're seen as
the foundation of life this conversation
usually turns at this point from the
heart to the brain
sure we can think of the body as a
machine and we could just put in
different parts to keep it running like
an automobile
but people are not cars people think
and while the physical body may still be
artificially maintained
human life is correlated with brain
activity
death in this view is not bodily death
which can be arbitrarily full stalled by
the use of life support mechanisms
but brain death this view is clearly
related to the classical metaphysical
picture
we called dualism in which there are two
completely different kinds of things
that make up a person
bodies and souls bodies are material
entities and souls
are something non-material now in latin
the language of intellectual discourse
until the last couple of centuries
the word anima was used for soul
but it also means mind it's the soul
that has judgment passed on it not the
body
even though the body was the one having
all the fun why judge the soul
because it decided what the body would
do
the body may have enjoyed the carnal
pleasures but it was the soul that sent
it to do what it did
in this way the notions of soul and mind
really are the same
in the dualistic view when someone is
brain dead
the body is still present but the will
the spirit
the mind is gone the soul has deserted
the body
the body is inanimate that is it has no
animus so the idea that brain death
is human death is tied to this picture
of the human body this dualistic view
that has largely been abandoned in
science
we don't think there's a second kind of
non-physical entity within
the body so why cling to brain death
as the essential property to define
human death
even if we think of the mind as emerging
from the brain
right the mind plays a crucial role in
being
human that the heart does not the mind
is what lets us plan
lets us choose what gives us autonomy
to be human is not merely to be alive
but to strive
to have a picture of where one is going
and to figure out
how to get there
as humans we may decide to watch a
stupid television program because we
know it'll make us laugh
we may choose to watch a lecture series
because we think it'll make us smarter
here we're back to heidegger we're not
present in the now but always exist
as our potential selves in the future
our choices will take time to happen
so we may say live for the moment but
really
we're living for the moment to come
the self we are not yet
but think we will be and that we think
we want to be the mind is what projects
us forward
and lets us choose when someone's brain
dead
there's not a self to project itself to
create itself
that is human life
after brain death it's not possible
of course the brain science we've looked
at makes this problematic too
because as we've seen as often as not
we act without thought the brain acts on
its own
and then the conscious parts backfill a
desire to match the action
we construct false but convincing
narratives that we chose
to take that cookie for reasons we
dreamed up really it was the amygdala
working on its own
so if the brain is not the seat of our
autonomy like we think it is
why should we believe that brain death
removes our personhood
indeed maybe we can resuscitate the
brain in the same way we can resuscitate
the heart
and if not now why not soon or at least
eventually
cryonics the cryogenic preservation of
one's body or at least one's head after
death by freezing
is undertaken by some as an attempt to
remain a human
even after death the hope is that if
technology now
can't cure the problem that caused death
surely in the future
an effective treatment will be found at
that time
the body could be thawed cured and
restored to a normal life
or the head could be attached to a new
or artificial body
ted williams widely considered to be the
greatest hitter in the history of
baseball
is the most famous person who's been
cryogenically frozen after death
we say that ted williams is dead but is
he still a person
if we think of that person whose heart
was restarted by the defibrillator
right we thought she was dead while she
had no heartbeat
but never stopped being a person because
she still had the potential for living
which was actualized by the shock from
the defibrillator
isn't the same thing true for teddy ball
game we generally think
not no he's dead he was a person
but is no longer
but what if we do find a way to
resuscitate him would he regain his
personhood
or would he have always kept it wouldn't
that make him like the woman whose life
was saved by cpr or the defibrillator
if that's true then brain death would
not be the true definition of death
the cessation of brain function would
not be what removed our personhood for
us
so we return to the question is death
the thing that removes our personhood
or is death what makes us
people we're made up of cells
and we have a natural life cycle of
birth growth aging and death
this is what happens for the body as a
whole because it also happens for the
cells individually
with few exceptions our cells replenish
themselves in our body by dividing
they split and make new young cells but
this
process does not create two exact copies
of the parent cell
recall that cells have nuclei and inside
the nucleus are chromosomes which
contain the dna
the instruction manual for the entire
enterprise now
the dna is in the form of a double helix
which unravels itself then the two have
split off
and recreate the other side because the
base pairs only pair up in a particular
way
as a result we have two copies of the
dna molecule
each of which can form the genetic
material needed
in the two cells that split out of the
progenitor
but dna is like a pair of pants
at the bottom of the leg of your pair of
pants is a hem
the place where the fabric is folded
over and sewn closed
why do we hem the bottom of pants think
what happens to homemade denim shorts we
make by cutting off the legs from a pair
of jeans
the ends fray they unravel they get
shorter losing their integrity they
slowly fall apart
dna is not only in your genes
it's like your genes if it weren't
hemmed at the end
it would unravel and fray
so we have what are called telomeres at
the end of the chromosomes
their discovery earned the nobel prize
for the australian geneticist
elizabeth blackburn and the americans
carol grider and jack sostak
these telomeres are the genetic
equivalent of hems
every time a cell divides the end of the
chromosome gets ripped
off so we have at the ends of the
chromosome
a series of meaningless repeating base
pairs t-t-a-g-g-g
t-t-a-g-g-g t-t-a-g-g-g
in the dna this is genetic code that
carries no information making it
disposable
indeed that's exactly its purpose with
each passing generation
a little bit more of the telomeres
shaved off making it shorter
when the telomere is gone the meaningful
genetic information
begins to get ripped off making the
cell's information incomplete
and making it impossible for it to do
its job since it doesn't have the full
manual
so once the telomere is gone the hem is
completely gone
and the cell becomes unable to divide
with the ends of the telomere
the cell dies unable to replace itself
through replication the telomere is
sometimes compared to a fuse
once it burns all the way down the cell
destroys itself
the effects of cell death in the body
are signs we all recognize
as aging our cells are pre-programmed to
age
and to die in a sense then so are we
it seems that we're designed with a
finite shelf life from the
inside out but it turns out
that telomere length is affected by
environment
and lifestyle choices smoking emotional
stress
lack of exercise are all associated with
shortened telomeres
while regular exercise a plant-based
low-carbohydrate diet
and stress management techniques are
associated with longer telomeres
but even those with longer telomeres
still have them shortened over time
their fuses burn more slowly but they
still burn
aging and death work at a slower pace
but the process
is still humming along leading to an
inevitable end
while that seems worrisome it actually
is helpful in a sense
every time a cell divides there's a
chance that the ripping a part of the
strands and the helix and the dna
will accidentally knock out a rung in
the ladder it gets replaced
but not always by the same base this
changes the genetic code
sometimes this isn't a problem but
sometimes it means
that the newly created dna has a wrong
manual
it gives the wrong instructions to the
cells it turns a cell from a helpful
part of the system
to a wrench in the system and as it
divides
it creates more and more copies of this
non-helping cell
the cells that need to be there working
hard to do the job they're supposed to
do in order to
get things done they get crowded out by
these do-nothing layabouts
we call this cancer by making sure
that cells only divide a certain number
of times we have an
internal means of trying to minimize
cancer risk
but then the cancer cells themselves
would die out too when their telomeres
run out right
well this is the interesting part
there's an enzyme called telomerase
and it builds back up the telomere in
cells it's a
like a little tailor going around and
re-hemming the pants inside the cells
in the case of some cancer cells they
produce their own
telomerase making them seemingly
immortal the cancer cells replenish
their fuses
so they never go off meaning that they
divide
and divide and divide while the healthy
cells die off
they crowd out the cells that are
supposed to be there and the resulting
tumor
grows until it interferes with the
body's ability to do what it needs to do
could we beat cancer at its own gain
could a cure to cancer be
finding a way to make the telomerase
ineffective
thus making the cancer cells burn
themselves out
and in the other direction could we use
telomerase
to lengthen the hems on the cells we
want to keep dividing
could we use telomerase inducers to
reverse aging
and make ourselves and therefore
possibly ourselves
immortal seems possible in mice
researchers engineered mice to have a
telomere switch
that is they would produce no telomerase
themselves until they were given a
particular
chemical which would start the
production inside their bodies
now at first the mice aged absurdly fast
becoming old and decrepit at a young age
but then they were given the chemical
which triggers the production of
telomerase
and the results startled even the
scientists who expected it
the premature aging reversed itself
at a stunningly quick pace the cells
regenerated
and the mice became young again the
telomerase partially reversed the aging
process
indeed researchers in barcelona showed
that telomerase treatments in mice
were capable of increasing lifespans
from 24
to 40 percent
the fear is that you're not only feeding
the good
cells but also supercharging the cancer
cells
interestingly however increases in
cancer rate
seem not to be associated with the
increased telomerase
it may be that in addition to feeding
the cancer cells
we're also keeping the cancer-killing
cells in the body young
or that the telomerase is keeping cells
from turning cancerous in the first
place
it's not known but there is a buzz about
the possibility of genetic
or medicinal treatments that could hold
the key to immortality
we fear death and as a result our
technology has raised the possibility of
avoiding it
but does this possibility rob us of our
humanity
the great argentine author jorge luis
borges thought so
in his story the immortal borges
considers what
immortality would do to a human and the
results are not pretty
when a roman soldier drinks from a river
that gives him immortality
he finds himself in a city full of
fellow immortals
the city is in ruins designed as a great
maze
at first he thought that this had to be
built by gods
but then he determines that no it was
built by mad men
the purpose of a maze is to baffle those
inside
but this was a maze with passages to
nowhere
blocked hallways for no reason it was
architecture he said
with no purpose
that building was a metaphor for the
immortals themselves
without a looming death life for them
had no purpose
they remained silent retreating inside
their own heads
they would never be taken away from this
world and so they intentionally
retreated from it
into themselves immortality gives you
time to do
everything and so nothing holds any
meaning any value
life itself becomes purposeless when
every purpose could be achieved
and an eternity still lay out in front
of you
the ron howard film cocoon on the other
hand takes a decidedly
more positive spin on the idea aliens
return
to earth to rescue some long-lost
compatriots and store the pods
protecting their bodies in a swimming
pool in florida
but the senior citizens from the
neighboring retirement community
had been sneaking in to use the pool and
when they bathed in the life-giving
medium
the aliens put in the pull to nourish
the pods the seniors are rejuvenated
giving back their youthful energy the
aliens discover them
as they discover the aliens the aliens
offer the seniors a chance to leave
earth and be granted
immortality almost all of the seniors
accept
they offer after both experiencing
eternal youth
and knowing what it means to age
would we choose immortality and would it
more closely resemble the portrayals of
borges
or cocoon would immortality rob
life of meaning or allow us the time
to do all we want and thereby allow us
to fully realize the complete potential
of our lives
regardless our technology continues to
point in the direction of immortality
would it make a difference to our
understanding of death
if we also had to reinterpret life and
birth
our technology is as busy addressing
concerns at the start of life
as it is dealing with those at the end
[Music]
you